Good morning John about 15 years ago
I, for the first time and begrudgingly
Took the myers-briggs personality test
the idea of that
specific personality test is to put you into one of two groups in four different categories, the most famous one being the first one. Are
You an introvert or an extrovert, are you an I or an E.
There's also how you gather information, is it sensing or intuition
How you make decisions?
Thinking or feeling. And finally, do you prefer to like make judgment or gather more information through perceiving or
prospecting. Two different "P"'s and it changes, so you might be like an
ENTP or an IS... FJ
At that time in my life I had
decided to hate
Personality tests like a great deal of my understanding of myself was like you can't put this in a box
This is why I was extremely pleased when my myers-briggs personality type came back as X N X P so for introvert extrovert
They couldn't classify me
I was right in the middle and for thinking or feeling also right in the middle so yeah
You can't put a college Hank in a box take that test tryin' to tell me that I am
Like anyone else to be fair to the test
I was pretty weird, like I loved to like go to parties and dance and like have people looking at me
but mostly because of how scary that was I love it in the way like that a
Parachuter loves jumping out of a plane like it's an extreme sport, but wanting to not be classifiable
It's not why I dislike personality tests now
I have a different reason and it's much more mild because I think it's extremely valuable to take some time for self-reflection and to assess
Ourselves and to understand ourselves and see what maybe are the right paths forward for who we are right now
But I also worry that the idea of a personality test leads to the belief that we are
What we are and we will never be anything else
I just took another myers-briggs personality test at
something's .com and as I was taking the test it became very clear to me that I've changed a lot and that like if I
Answered these questions as five years ago Hank
I would be answering them differently. I am much more of a planner where I used to be an improviser and part of that's having
a child
But part of that's having like a team of 15 people that are not ready for me to email them at (studder)
Midnight to be like tomorrow
We're gonna do this new thing that can be frustrating for an employee it turns out and it turns out that I actually like working
That way it's a little less scary, and it is become the default way I operate and also now
I'm not in the middle of introvert/extrovert
I am way over in the extrovert side and anybody who knows me will tell you that
so this is the time of year when
People might be setting goals for how they want to behave or how they want things to go in
2018 and what that means is changing behavior, and that is friken hard because we
Emphasize these neural pathways ways that we act things we do with our hands
How we interact with other people what we give value to all those neural pathways get
More and more structured and changing them gets more difficult
And I want to make the case
that it really doesn't help if we believe that we were born to only ever be one way ever
We change hour to hour based on situations
And we change a decade to decade there's something very simple about feeling like you'll never change and about taking a test and knowing
Who you are, but we're not that simple
I think it's a disservice to the complexity of
You absolutely find ways to live that work for you and people who appreciate you for the way
You are but also know that if you want to change you can and even if you don't you probably will so if you have
A moment I have an exercise can you write down in the comments for all of us to read something
That you changed about yourself. It could be something simple like you changed
How you write "A'"s or it can be more complicated like you decided to be the kind of person who listens more and talks less
I mean if there's somebody here who needs to take that advice
I don't know
And if you want you could also share some of the ways that you hope to maybe change in the future because you were not
Carved in stone the day you were born you are molding yourself out of clay, and if you don't keep it moving
It's gonna harden up. John. I'll see you on Tuesday
If you ever want to learn more about this stuff with a great deal more rigor than was in this video
Check out our channel Scishow psych, it's all about the science of psychology